the city who have the high fort and will
host
2030 another
sporting victory for qatar's capital
doha this time
winning the rights to host the 2030
asian games
the second biggest multi-sport event
after the olympics
doha beating saudi arabia's capital
riyadh in a vote by the olympic council
of asia
riyad will host the 2034 edition
this achievement wasn't made just today
but it's the result of 16 years of hard
work
we are proud of this historical moment
today we have won the bid for 2030
and it's no surprise the wider context
of two
regional rivals going head to head in
this vote is hard to ignore
since 2017 saudi arabia along with
bahrain the united arab emirates and
egypt has imposed a blockade on qatar
but for both nations there is more than
political point scoring at play
with qatar already looking beyond the
football world cup it will host in two
years time
as we know qatar has effectively built a
nation
um based upon sport so
a lot of its infrastructure a lot of its
um
urban developments have been connected
to
the staging of the world cup and so it
was absolutely crucial i think in terms
of legacy
and in terms of delivering a return on
investment for these uh
uh from its um various projects
to not only deliver the world cup but to
subsequently also host
other mega events
[Music]
in 2006 doha held the asian games for
the first time
it was the starting point of an
ambitious plan to make qatar a global
sporting hub since then the country has
hosted a series of major events
including
last year's world athletics
championships and in 2022 the football
world cup will be coming to qatar
the nation has made no secret of its
desire to one day host an olympics
with 2032 now looking an increasingly
realistic target
andy richardson al jazeera doha